- Danny, you and Jordan,
you knew each other before
the group though, right?
That's what he was saying, yeah?
- Well the four of us, me,
Donnie, Jordan and John,
all went to elementary school together.
- No way!
- Like since we were this big.
Yeah, we knew each other
since kindergarten, basically.
- [Kelly] I didn't know that.
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] Do you know how many people
still have friends from that age?
No one, that's crazy.
- We do.
- We were.
We were friends.
Danny and I used to sit
together on the school bus.
John was best friends
with my brother, Bob,
and then him and I became
friends in the sixth grade.
Jordan was singing in all
the plays and we knew him.
And anyway, go back to your story.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] That's amazing though to have
that kind of connection
at such a young age
and then even through
like your whole life?
No, not many people have that.
- Nah, it's a blessing and it
makes it easy to work together
because we know each other so well,
and it's beyond even what brothers are,
I got a lot of love for these guys.
- Oh, Danny.
- Danny.
- You're definitely able to
call them out on their (beep)
when you know them that long.
Yeah?
Well these next ladies were friends
before they were making
music together as well.
They were the first all-female
rap group to go platinum.
I'm super stoked they're here.
Give it up for Salt-N-Pepa!
(audience applause)
(upbeat hip hop music)
♪Salt-N-Pepa's here ♪
- Good to see ya!
- I know that.
I love that.
I wish I,
It's so awkward.
I was telling them in
the break, I was like,
I'm a such a hugger.
- I know.
And it's such a weird thing
You lose a lot of the,
like the beginning part of a
conversation when you're like.
Hey.
- You gotta fist bumper, elbow bump.
Hi guys .
- Hi!
- Okay. So wait, how did
you start working together?
Cause you've known each other.
You were friends first, right?
- Yes. We went to school together.
We were in, what is it?
Queensboro.
- College.
- College. I'm leaving out the community.
- That's right.
- She don't like when I say that.
(multiple people talking)
- Get your basics out of
the way, it's cheaper.
Then go the other way.
Everybody frowns upon that.
It's smart.
- So, we went to college together
and we also worked at Sears as
telephone solicitors
together. I got her a job.
They were hiring. She was
like, I want to work at Sears.
I said, they'll hire anybody.
(laughter)
- They hired Pep.
- Yes.
And the funny thing about
Sears is Martin Lawrence worked
there, Kid 'n Play, Salt-N-Pepa
and Herbie Lovebug, our producer,
and everyone went on to do
what they set out to do.
There's something in the water at Sears.
- [Kelly] Sears was the training ground.
- [Salt] Thanks Sears!
- That's amazing. So did
you always know each other,
you always knew that you
wanted to be Salt-N-Pepa,
like you always wanted to do group?
- No.
We was just at college and Sears,
playing cards in the lunch room.
- Hanging out.
- Hanging out and everything.
But then I, you know, Herbie,
our producer, you know,
he was going to a music
school at the time.
So he wanted to put the
group together. And,
so I auditioned.
(laughter)
- and got it. No.
- I'm like, why are you laughing?
It's worked out.
- The thing about Salt-N-Pepa
is like, we're opposite.
But we're also very much
alike, which is weird.
And you know how opposites attract?
I always say the chemistry between us is
she pulls me to the edge and
I keep her from going over.
You know, we just teeter right there.
- I was like, come to the edge.
Live a little bit more.
- Have fun.
Calm down.
- Right, Right.
- One of my inspirations,
actually, all of these people
are my musical inspiration.
So I'm having a good day people,
but one of them, this next group though,
of another iconic act on
the mixed tape Tour 2022.
They're one of my favorite
female vocal groups.
I think everybody loves them.
They're one of the best groups
in the history of people
making music on this planet.
En Vogue y'all!
(crowd applause)
(upbeat hip hop music)
- Are we coming down?
- Oh my gosh!
- Y'all better walk.
(laughter)
- So, I mean, you guys,
first of all, welcome.
I'm so excited that you're here.
(applause)
And I was saying earlier,
like all of you are like
musical inspirations for me.
Like, and still I still like,
literally my Spotify
playlist is all 90s music.
Because it's the best!
- Thank you.
- Have you had a chance though?
Like to people that you were inspired by,
like if you had a chance to meet with
or sing with like people
that really like inspired
you to be who you are.
- Absolutely.
- Who are those people for you?
- So many people early.
When we first got in the game.
Gladys Night.
- Oh God.
- Patti LaBelle.
- Wow.
- Chaka Khan.
- Yeah.
- All the real divas. The real divas.
- Wow. Oh my God. Chaka.
So, okay, so Cindy,
you learned that you could
harmonize in a really unique way
when you were a kid, right?
- I did. I was six years old.
It was to the bugs
bunny theme with my dad.
I didn't know what
harmonizing was, but he said,
you sing this part, I'm
going to sing this part.
And, and that was harmonizing.
And I was like, ah,
- That's amazing that you kept it.
Because usually kids,
even they'll stray to whatever
the other person singing.
That's amazing .
- I just,
my dad was a singer and it was
just music in the household
all the time, my sister.
So I just, it just clicked.
- Wow. That's beautiful.
And Joey, you were very
young whenever you started.
So this is a real question.
Because I grew up singing with guys.
Does your voice change then
while you're in the group?
- Oh, it changed like,
Yeah.
I got, actually my voice
changed right after,
Our first single was,
Please Don't Go Girl.
- Yeah.
- And my voice hadn't changed.
So just as it was coming out,
as we were doing all
the promo for that song,
I could still sing the song.
And then right when Right Stuff
came along, it was a wrap.
My voice just changed.
So it was like, God was like,
I'm going to, I'm going to save it,
just enough to get this single out.
And then we're going to change.
- That's what I always feel bad for,
because guys that I grew up a lot of guys
singing and I was like, oh my God.
And then all of a sudden,
your voice just changes.
- Yeah. Great reason
for being in a band too,
because you got other guys
that can get your back.
- Oh, I went about this the wrong way.
(applause)
- All right, so Terry.
What about a memorable,
like early gig for you?
- A memorable, early gig.
- There's got to be a lot.
- There was this one moment
and it was just so pivotal
for us, when we performed
with Stevie Wonder.
- What?
Like all the names you're dropping.
- Recorded a song with
him called What the Fuss.
And we were in the studio
and when we, it wasn't our
first time meeting him.
But what was so crazy
was when we got there,
he called us each of us out by name.
And we were looking at each
other like how in the world?
- Oh, because he can't? Oh.
- Right!
We were like, wait, can he see.
(laughter)
We did this other gig. And he was there.
And why did he you know, we had,
we were interacting with each other.
And why did he call out our birthdays?
- What?
- Years later.
- Okay. He was the guy on top of your bus.
(laughter)
- Yeah. We remember.
He was like Terry,
I was like, I was so taken aback.
I was like, oh my God,
like Stevie, come on.
Can you see?
- Oh my God.
Are you lying to me right now?
What's funny though is
like, no, not you, him.
- Oh.
- Like, are you lying?
You're like I promise I'm not lying.
So what about y'all? What are some,
like a memorable moment that
you love from your career?
- Woo. There's so many, The Grammys.
- The Grammys.
The Grammy's one of them,
because we, when we petitioned it,
because they weren't doing, you know,
showing when you won an award or, you know
the Grammys at the time, Hip Hop,
they weren't showing it on television.
- Oh they weren't airing that award?
- They wouldn't air it.
And we,
so we like petitioned it and everything.
And then once with Will Smith.
- Will Smith and a bunch of other artists.
- Yeah.
And then we went on to win
one and it was televised.
So it was like, oh my gosh.
So it was a big moment for us,
for women in Hip Hop, you know.
(applause)
- It's always a sad thing,
because you're like,
I know people that have won
Grammys and they're like,
it wasn't televised.
And it was like maybe
their first time to do it.
And it's like, oh man, what a bummer?
- Yeah.
Like, because he was a kid or
like, you have that moment.
You think of that happen, you know,
I'm so glad you got that. That's amazing.
- Yes.
- And you were like, we deserve this.
And then it happened.
- Exactly.